CHRIS?
BACK TO YOU.
SPOON DEIRDRE BOLTON OF THE
FOX BUSINESS NETWORK AT THE END
OF A WILD WEEK.
GET SOME REST.
YOU PROBABLY SLEPT THROUGH THE
SECOND GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN OF
THE NEW YEAR.
IT CAME AND WENT OVERNIGHT.
JUST LIKE BEFORE, THE TEMPORARY
SOLUTION COMES WITH AN
EXPIRATION DATE NOT TOO FAR IN
THE FUTURE.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY IS ON
CAPITOL HILL TONIGHT TO TELL US
ABOUT THIS NEW DEAL AND SOME
MAJOR BACKPEDALING BY THE G.O.P.
>> REOPENING THE GOVERNMENT
REQUIRED A BIG REVERSAL FOR
REPUBLICANS.
HERE IS WHY.
BACK IN 2011 WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WANTED TO RAISE
THE DEBT CEILING, REPUBLICANS
REQUIRED HIM TO IMPOSE BUDGET
CAPS TO HARNESS SPENDING.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WE WILL -- WE
WILL RAISE THE DEBT CEILING.
BUT ONLY IF YOU AGREE TO CUT UP
THE CREDIT CARDS.
>> THIS MORNING, REPUBLICANS
WANTED TO FREEZE THE DEBT
CEILING.
THEY MADE A DEAL.
THEY GOT RID OF THOSE CAPS TO DO
IT.
>> DON’T YOU REMEMBER WHEN
REPUBLICANS HOWLED TO HIGH
HEAVEN THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS
SPENDING US INTO THE GUTTER!
SPENDING US INTO OBLIVION!
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SWINGS THE
BALANCE OF POWER, TWEETING,
WITHOUT MORE REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS, WE WERE FORCED TO
INCREASE SPENDING ON THINGS WE
DO NOT LIKE OR WANT IN ORDER TO
FINALLY, AFTER MANY YEARS OF
DEPLETION, TAKE CARE OF OUR
MILITARY.
SADLY, WE NEEDED SOME DEM VOTES.
MUST ELECT MORE REPUBLICANS TO
2018 ELECTION.
TODAY, HE SIGNED A BILL THAT
WILL KEEP THE GOVERNMENT FUNDED
TO MARCH 23RD, THAN OVER 2 YEARS
SPENT $6 MILLION FIGHTING OPIOID
ADDICTION, PUTS 20 BILLION
TOWARDS INFRASTRUCTURE, AND
REPEALS OBAMACARE’S INDEPENDENT
PAYMENT ADVISORY BOARD.
BUT THE LACK OF RESTRAINT HAS
PROMINENT CONSERVATIVES SERIOUS.
>> THERE’S NOT ANY PRETENSE HER
HERE!
AND BALANCING A BUDGET?
SPEAKER ON PAPER, IT’S HARD TO
BELIEVE THE BIPARTISAN --
WHO CUT THIS 2011 VIDEO.
>> WE WILL CUT SPENDING.
>> SPEAKER RYAN INSIST THERE ARE
SOME THINGS EVEN THE MOST
RESPONSIBLE FISCAL HAWKS CAN’T
LAND FOR PRINT >>
MUCH OF THIS DEFICIT SPENDING IS
ONE TIME SPENDING.
IT’S HURRICANE RELIEF.
WHAT, WE’RE NOT GONNA REBUILD
HOUSTON PLACEMENT WE’RE NOT
GOING TO REBUILD FLORIDA?
WE AREN’T GOING TO HELP
PUERTO RICO OR THE WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA?
>> IN A MOSTLY EMPTY CAPITAL
TODAY, I SAW THE WHITE HOUSE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS DIRECTOR
MARC SHORT WHO SAID HE WAS HERE
FOR MEETINGS WITH REPUBLICAN
OPTIONS ABOUT DACA THROUGH NEXT
WEEK, DACA TALKS ARE REALLY
GOING TO PICK UP THE HEAD OF THE